our props again alright alright yo me we
got this oh yeah they didn't send a
chance if we see a giant shark we know
it's not real one yeah sure mark what do
we think of I don't know hey don't you
be is this just what you move over okay
there we go where did you go oh okay do
I look reasonable do I look horrible
no you look fine for mine how do I look
you look completely natural I thought
this is where you are going straight off
the bed I saw this last round no I
didn't even notice this is fantastic I
love it so I'll give you guys a huge
starting hint since this is a little
unfair yeah neither of us it's in the
water yeah flashing around there in
socre town so I just fancied having a
smoke city soak city that's what it was
yeah soak city like a bunch of splashing
around like a bunch of fish they
couldn't wait
full-time hidden in the same room that
we might actually survive yeah and if we
win we get to be props again
[Laughter]
don't worry Wade I'm happy man they've
gotta be in there right hi I don't know
where
we are we are I don't even know when we
are yeah it is I don't see anything yet
well wait that's cuz you're bad at games
your best bet would just be to throw
grenades randomly and hope you can't and
hope you don't kill yourself what if
what if yeah man she never actually left
the room yeah what if I was just
something really douchey and tidy he
definitely left the room there's no way
I would have left him when I catch a
sense I never letting standing still oh
I see 30 seconds left I did not look at
the top I should have just stayed where
it was as that barrel oh wait we're Oh
lady eye in the sky this is some cow
poop I don't think it's any sort of poop
mister I think it's a there's so much
poop I am breathing poop enough that
they'll never see it I'm taking this
yeah apparently you are goodbye goodbye
goodbye
[Laughter]
I've certain calamity into not calamity
because I I messed up and apparently I'm
in a good spot I wish I could see what's
going on Bob died first so you could
find where I am I can find a hilarious
way to die huh
are you someplace like really obvious or
something when it's obvious it's hard to
find oh hey hey you come back here wait
Bob some bananas and I'm killing
something
you're killing mark what are you on my
screen they are stuck in the wall I
wonder if we get to be props again for
no my sweating uh okay there you go have
fun with your little prop Ennis
we will we haven't made a face this
episode my lip is still split open from
the face we'd pull when we try seduce a
woman ohh
let's seduce the whole audience out that
all right are you ready think on that
[Music]
okay what these times just gonna let me
do it by myself and do you booty over
smashing plants like a loser
somehow it doesn't sound as cool is that
your me impression wait really
[Music]
[Laughter]
water what you guys know whatever there
what are you doing watching you watching
you jump all you didn't make that jump
all you missed it again oh you made that
side though that's good up see you later
you enjoying yourself weed oh I'm loving
this someone just went in the building
someone else is underwater he just
dropped one of the girls in that room Oh
someone just opened the gate on the
other side Bob I think they're trying to
mess with us
play your game the ones in the building
I can't see them they're moving around
all the little shooting he's shooting
one of the drawers I'm not in this room
don't mind me drop that snot me there's
something fishy going on up there
getting a bit low on help over there I
see I don't where am I in this room I
can see everything you do but I'm not in
the room I don't like it out of you pool
put that shot stick away that's not
scaring it now
[Laughter]
chasing you around as a fish no well
maybe I was kind of following you guys
around as a fish yeah I think the fish
is chewed whatever it's a bummer moving
around
hello mr. Barrow oh not what what's that
anymore I love being props all the time
this game is so much more fun when
you're just no it's awesome
I like seeking okay I like to find try
that's all I being a prop sucks
oh isn't that right Wade this time it
does yeah oh okay not so bad air verbal
error horrible error I think you said
probably horrible horrible error yeah
[Music]
Wade you take that back error two errors
or once an error in their own way I'm
not an error I was an error I wasn't
supposed to be born Oh
no literally my parents were like on ten
different types of contraceptive in
those anyway Jen different kinds ten ten
different that's a lot is there even why
would you need that many at once I don't
know like my mom has no boundaries when
it comes to talking about like her prior
sex life or anything like that so she
just tells me these stories about how I
was born and they were using like
condoms anti spermicides she was on the
pill whoever that was that just found my
trashcan you just saw you I was actually
coming back for just missed me I'm gone
that baby oh think anyone's gonna find
me just because I'm actually hiding and
I'm actually hiding you know blending in
where are you mark I don't okay can you
say Bob is that your me impression no
that was like like Timmy or something
okay but what's the guy is a comedian on
self oh yeah that's Jimmy Jim Jeffy
Jimmy Jimmy there's Timmy and then
there's Jimmy Timmy I don't know I bet
it's not Jimmy cuz I bet Jimmy's the one
that's always like Jimmy oh hi so it was
real close to me I didn't even see you
should we like we need some type of put
it aside you're in the water because
this is tough ah I am NOT in the water
oh oh I'm on it yeah I am in the water
and the water ways you get Bob I am in
the water and I am not moving
oh my gosh I'm stuck in a glitch well
this is my life now it's a little too
easy to become sucked up what's your
glitch bah
let me relieve you of it glitch is that
what you're saying yeah satisfies glitch
yeah that walked right passing in that
little brew someone keeps running by me
I don't know who it is I never get a
chance to see me yeah you upon your pond
on a plant why would I be a plant
oh I can see you now oh are you lying to
me no can't see say you're around here
yeah you kept walking by me so I just
keep swimming I think it'd be a bear oh
no I can't actually get myself out of
this glitch so here that's not me I want
to see what happened to Bob why why
don't you just go to the surface in here
really not that garbage can
I'm not I was a garbage can I was never
that one that Grover's kids not damaging
me to hit oh there's lots of stuff I
just did that okay really Bob I told you
it was a glitch where is he
I never would have thought to look up
there yeah well I was it was a traffic
cone stuck on a ladder I'm still
underwater by the soda machine you will
find a literary surprise soda machine
only blow your mind goodbye whoosh do
that I don't know Oh drop kill to you
okay well I buy up a negative one I
don't want to have negative one okay
whatever you guys are doing it's
hilarious I hear a lot of opening and
closing yeah I hear the doors open
so we'll see what you guys do over there
swimming on my screen it's beautiful
okay all right so I see you guys up
there running around like a loser loser
yeah I take offense to your comment sir
hey who's in the who's in the cage the
what in the cage is he like a loser is
he is there a way to get out of there if
I close you in listen I can see huge
[Laughter]
nice try dick I just wanted you to be
trapped in that room the rest of the
game I'm sorry that's not the way this
world hey it's a file boxes input
usually on top are gone yeah well Wade
was a stool so if that tells you
anything he was a stolen the water so
was a stool in the water no no that kind
of gives it away don't it yeah I'm not a
jerk like the other two iPhones up
bicycle no I did yeah I'm I'm stuck I
can't but the good news is I'm not stuck
in a weird position so it's gonna be
hard to find me right now I'm in the
water for the first you get a clue every
30 seconds okay what's my next clue you
got 15 seconds hold your horses
have a bit of patience young man no I
don't I don't I don't
oh wait no dessert for you like
it's alright no there are eight two
seconds next clue
I'm very some quite small that's a good
clue under this water with all these
small things oh yeah I can't fire my
grenade oh I got an idea I'm gonna die
got a line up my shot line this up just
right okay nope I was no I saw you miss
okay I'm on the side which has old the
rooms in the objects not the side with
the cage really yeah are you this little
bottle that's obviously out of place
[Music]
he's you there Bob you're going nuts oh
I thought for half a second there I was
gonna be in apropos her own joke no no
Bob this rounds going that's my spot you
can't get up there anyway
wait way to screw it up Go Go mark we're
stuck we are well they appeared I've
noticed so I think oh hi this is you
right you know these two barrels right
yeah
[Laughter]
yeah I think we're invincible because
we're stuck together like this oh yeah
are you not are you not taking any
damage no I'm the top bar oh you hit the
bomb one let's do this we are no other
choice when you find us you'll feel
really stupid really stupid dad dang it
use the stacked ovens no no definitely
not Bob let's just commit to our fate if
they can't find us here I think it's
working I can't move this is what
happens with his face and what I am with
my face is together are you under water
that's that's gonna make it really easy
I feel like you can't even give you clue
it is so obvious really yeah I think
yeah I guess not apparently what if they
don't find it everything looks normal
Bob maybe we're invisible or something
give us like another clue or so yeah
I see Bob what clue I I can see you I
know from where we are we can see
everything yeah the water running out of
our sight yeah ah well Kos
wait I how I have no idea ever headache
this doesn't make any sense traffic more
obvious because you can't even see the
fish till you write up on it but there
was never a traffic cone there oh my
gosh I can't believe that happened oh my
god oh I can't believe we got stuck like
that that's stupid it was the fish
I was the fish you were the more outside
of Bob's cone
[Music]